peu
dieu que cette histoire finie mais on
n'imagine jamais
très bien d'une histoire puisse unir
steven quand alors comme
si bien
on imagine pourtant
très bien partout
perdu
le temps
mais tristes heures
l'instant
alors
qui ce se qui nous passent entre
[Musique]
peut-être
finissons par nous lasser
si seulement nous avions le courageux
soysal qui change
dans le vent glacé
tourner ton dos contre monde
que vas-tu
je te vois plus
si c'est ainsi qu'on
continue
je ne donne pas cher
nos pros
parfois qui sait ce qui nous passe en
tête peut-être
mini sans nous pas assez si seulement
nous avions le goût acheter
loiseau
qui change
dans le vent glacé
si seulement nous savions le courage des
oiseaux
qui change
dans le vent glacé
[Musique]